MICHAEL FLYNN MIGHT NOT HAVE HAD
THE INTENT TO LIE.
HE'S TRYING TO WITHDRAW THAT
GUILTY PLEA.
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THIS PANEL
GOING.
LET'S BRING IN REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN FROM THE GREAT STATE
OF THE WISCONSIN SEAN DUFFY.
BIG BREAKING NEWS NIGHT.
WE HAVE ANDREW McCABE, DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI FIRED BEFORE
HIS BIG PENSION WOULD KICK IN.
SOME CRYING FOUL, SAYING THIS
FIRE IS POLITICAL, BUT IT WAS
DONE AT THE BEHEST OF THE OPR
OFFICE, WHICH IS NOT A POLITICAL
OFFICE AND THERE'S CONCLUSIONS
ABOUT HIS CONDUCT DEVASTATING.
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY.
>> YES, I CRITICIZED JEFF
SESSIONS QUITE A BIT THAT HE
HELD BACK AND WAITS FOR THE
OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO GIVE US THE
RECOMMENDATION.
HE HANDLED IT CORRECTLY.
BUT LAURA, WE HAVE A FORMER HEAD
OF THE FBI THAT IS NOW FIRED.
I THINK SHOWS THE SYSTEM
ACTUALLY CAN WORK.
I LOOK AT THE FBI.
NOT THE BOOTS ON THE GROUND BUT
AT THE TOP OF THE FBI, THIS
PLACE IS ROTTEN.
THANK GOD DONALD TRUMP WAS
ELECTED TO CLEAN OUT THESE
ROTTEN OFFICIALS THAT ARE
PLAYING PARTISANSHIP WITH THIS
AGENCY.
THINK BACK TO LOIS LEARNER.
TARGETED CONSERVATIVES AND
CONSERVATIVE GROUPS.
THE STATUS QUO IS YOU LEAVE THEM
PEOPLE IN AND LET THEM GET THEIR
PENSIONS.
UNDER DONALD TRUMP, YOU START
FIRING PEOPLE THAT VIOLATE THE
ETHICS WITHIN THEIR AGENCY ON
THE LAW.
THIS IS A GREAT THING.
>> Laura: YEAH, FRANK MONTOYA
SAYING THIS IS A POLITICAL HIT
JOB ON McCABE.
THE FACT HIS WIFE RAN FOR OFFICE
AS A DEMOCRAT, THE ATTACKS ON
HIS COMPETENCE ARE WAY OUT OF
LINE.
SARAH?
>> AGAIN, NO.
THIS CAN'T BE A POLITICAL HIT
JOB IF OPR, THE OFFICE OF
PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY, GOT
DOCUMENTATION, PROVABLE FACTS
THAT HE VIOLATED HIS OATH AS AN
FBI AGENT AND LIED.
WHO DID HE LIE TO?
HE LIED TO THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
AND THIS COULD BE LEADING TO
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
THEY WANT TO DEFEND HIM.
IT'S A TRAGEDY THAT WE SEE THIS
HAPPEN BUT WE NEED TO KNOW THE
TRUTH AND THE FBI AND OTHER
AGENCIES NEED TO BE CLEANED OUT.
>> Laura: WAS HE UNDER
INVESTIGATION BEFORE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION?
WAS THIS PREDATING DONALD TRUMP?
I KEEP HEARING WHISPERS ABOUT
THAT.
>> THERE ARE WHISPERS.
PART OF THAT IS DUE TO THE FACT
THAT HE WAS UNDER INVESTIGATION
FOR HAT JACK VIOLATIONS.
HE WAS REFERRED BY SENATOR
GRASSLY AS WELL FOR NOT
APPROPRIATELY DISCLOSING THE --
>> Laura: TERRY McAULIFFE.
>> YEAH.
ISSUE THERE'S.
A SEXUAL HARASSMENT LAWSUIT.
THERE WERE ISSUES THERE THAT HE
HAD TO DEAL WITH.
THIS INVESTIGATION SPIRALLED OUT
OF THE EVIDENCE THAT CAME FORD
WHEN WE STARTED TO REALIZE THAT
McCABE WAS AT THE CENTER OF
THIS, COMEY, TEXT MESSAGES, THE
INVESTIGATION THAT MICHAEL
HOROWITZ HAS DONE.
>> Laura: SEAN, HOLD THAT
THOUGHT.
WE HAVE CONGRESSMAN MARK MEADOWS
CONGRESSMAN MEADOWS, WE FOR
MONTHS HAVE BEEN SAYING HOW DID
YOU HAVE THE SAME PEOPLE WHO
WERE INVESTIGATING HILLARY'S
PRIVATE E-MAIL SERVER ALSO
OVERSEE THE INVESTIGATION INTO
DONALD TRUMP'S POSSIBLE
COLLUSION WITH THE RUSSIANS?
WE SAW THAT WITH PETER STRZOK.
WE FOUND HIS TEXT MESSAGES AND
NOW THE CONCLUSION BY THE OFFICE
OF PROFESSIONAL RESPONSIBILITY
ABOUT ANDREW McCABE LEADING TO
HIS FIRING TONIGHT.
YOUR REACTION TO THIS HUGE
BREAKING NEWS NIGHT, CONGRESSMAN
MEADOWS.
>> IT'S UNBELIEVABLE NEWS.
THE FACT THAT NOBODY EVER GETS
FIRED FROM THE FBI AND DOJ
WITHOUT THERE BEING REAL
CREDIBLE EVIDENCE.
SO THE SUGGESTION THIS IS A
POLITICAL HIT JOB IS NOT
ACCURATE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES OF OPR, THEY
HAVE CERTAIN GUIDELINES THAT
THEY GO BY.
BUT WHAT IT DOES CALL INTO
QUESTION, LAURA, IS THIS: IF YOU
HAVE PETER STRZOK AND ANDY
McCABE BOTH HAVING QUESTIONABLE,
YOU KNOW, ACTIONS ON THEIR PART,
WHAT DOES IT MEAN ABOUT THE
WHOLE INVESTIGATION AND WHAT IS
LED UP TO THAT?
I CAN TELL YOU THERE'S MORE
INFORMATION COMING.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL IS DOING A
VERY GOOD JOB.
BUT THIS ACTION TONIGHT WOULD
NOT HAVE HAPPENED IF THERE WAS
NOT CREDIBLE WRONG DOING ON THE
PART OF ANDREW McCABE.
>> Laura: WHAT ABOUT THE MORALE
OF THE FBI AT THIS POINT?
WE'VE HEARD FOR SOME TIME THAT
THERE'S BEEN A DESPERATELY LOW
MORALE.
CREDIBILITY OF THE FBI BEING
QUESTIONED THE LAST FEW YEARS,
EVEN GOING BACK TO 9-11 WITH THE
CIA AND THE INTELLIGENCE THERE.
THE INTEL COMMUNITY HAVE THIS
VAUNTED REPUTATION.
THEY'RE THERE TO PROTECT US.
WHAT ABOUT THEIR MORALE,
CONGRESSMAN DUFFY?
CAN IT BEGIN TO RECOVER?
IS THIS SEEN AS A SHOT ACROSS
THE BOW?
PROFESSIONAL CAREER AGENTS.
THEY DON'T LIKE THIS CLOUD
HANGING OVER THE FIB.
THEY JUST WANT TO DO THEIR JOB.
THERE'S GOOD PEOPLE THERE.
>> THEY SHOW UP, THEY SIGN UP TO
DO THEIR JOB.
WHEN YOU HAVE THE TOP OF AN
AGENCY OR A BUREAU ROTTEN LIKE
THIS, IT'S DISHEARTENING.
YOU GIVE THEM HOPE WHEN YOU
CLEAR IT OUT AND WE'RE GOING TO
GET BACK TO THE BASICS.
SO THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF A
NEW AND FRESH START.
WE'VE BEEN WONDERING, HOW DID
THESE LEAKS HAPPEN?
HOW ARE THE STORIES GETTING TO
THE PRESS THE LAST 1 1/2 YEARS
ON DONALD TRUMP AND THE
INVESTIGATION?
NOW WE SEE IT WAS COMING FROM
ANDREW McCABE AND FROM JAMES
COMEY HIMSELF.
THE QUESTION I HAVE, REMEMBER
WHEN COMEY WENT AND BRIEFED
DONALD TRUMP ON THE DOSSIER?
NO ONE REPORTED ON THE DOSSIER
UNTIL SOMEONE LEAKED THAT COMEY
WAS BRIEFING THE PRESIDENT ON
THE -- OR THE PRESIDENT-ELECT,
DONALD TRUMP, ON THE DOSSIER.
THEY LEAKED THAT TO CNN.
EVERY NEWS OUTLET COULD REPORT
ON THE DOSSIER.
THE LEAKING WAS ADVANCING THEIR
STORY AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.